on penrose has just resigned as the
prime minister's anti-corruption czar
let's hear why and what he's got say i
think the letter's just gone into the
prime minister john why did you take
your decision well thank you beth last
week just before the jubilee weekend the
prime minister responded for the first
time um to the sugray report in terms of
the ministerial code and clearly if you
break the ministerial code in a material
way it's expected that you'll resign
it's the first time he'd responded on
that basis and i'm afraid it left far
too many questions unanswered i was
looking at his response over the weekend
and it's pretty clear that one of the
fundamental principles underlying the
ministerial code which every minister
including the prime minister is expected
to follow is of leadership and integrity
those are core as a part of the the uh
the seven principles of public life he's
broken both of those or it seems very
clear that he has the sue grey report
says so in terms it says there are major
problems with leadership and he hasn't
addressed that at all in his response i
think at that point it's pretty clear
that he has broken the ministerial code
in a very material way and at that point
hey i'm afraid it's normally a
resignation matter for the minister
concerned and but also clearly i as the
anti-corruptions are can't carry on in
that role um until unless this is
addressed
and john penrose you talked about
integrity um and standards in public
office
this is a character problem for boris
johnson isn't it mps are not
going against him because of policy
matters they're going against it about
the essence of the man
i think that's some of it yes i mean
other people will have different reasons
for voting either in favor or against um
in the vote of confidence later on today
and but this was a letter that i wrote
yesterday before i even knew there was
going to be a vote of confidence today
so some people will be voting for
precisely the reasons you said other
people will have other concerns i'm sure
they'll tell you if you can pin them in
a corner and get them to give you an
interview and john penrose i'm assuming
that you've put uh you've resigned
you've put in a letter of of no
confidence as well well the the the vote
of no confidence is this evening i'm
afraid i'm left with no option but to
vote uh for the government for the for
the prime minister to go and my letter
resigning and suggesting to the prime
minister that he should resign as well
on the basis of having broken the
ministerial code went into number 10
earlier this morning and did you hear
back from the prime minister not yet to
be fair
in his defense he's only had a couple of
minutes so far so it would be it would
be premature and mr penrose just in
terms of how other colleagues are
feeling you obviously went home you
reflected on it uh over
uh recess you decided that in your
position you had to resign and you'd
lost confidence in him what have your
conversations been like with colleagues
is this a real conscience issue for many
mps i think for quite a lot yes it is i
mean different people will reach
different conclusions and i completely
respect that there are valid views on
all sides so i don't want to criticize
people who feel differently from me but
yes for many a lot of us were saying
look wait for the su grey report and now
i don't think this is organized i think
what's happening is that people are
having to reply to their constituents
the sugray report having come out um and
they're basically saying can i look at
myself in the mirror in the morning um
and and you know look myself in the eye
and feel like i've done the right thing
and mr penrose jacob rees-mogg i just
interviewed him as dk on on sky news he
says the prime minister wins by one vote
that's enough
that is this matter done it doesn't feel
like that to me what do you think what
is he done whichever way now oh i i fear
that that is probably the case i think
it's over um i fee it feels now like a
question of when not if but we will have
to wait and see what the result is if he
has a thumping victory this evening um
then that might be different but it you
know at the moment insofar as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
what's the thumping victory look like i
haven't got a clue we'll have i'll talk
to you about it afterwards if you like
and mr pembroke's just just in terms of
in terms of uh
the rebellion if you like because you
know precedent is that prime ministers
typically
win these ballots but they are
potentially fatally damaged by
uh the size of the rebellion and even
the fact that the vote gets called
particularly when you have a 79 seat
majority not perhaps where the prime
minister thought he might be
if over a hundred mps vote against the
prime minister tonight that means over
half of his backbenchers no longer have
confidence in him at that point does he
have to resign whether he wants to or
not well i think that the the question
will be whether or not he can
whether or not he could carry on whether
or not he can address any of the issues
which have been raised and i think it
will be very very difficult and
certainly history says
that if it's a sizable rebellion but i'm
not quite sure what that number is i
don't think anybody really knows um then
it's very difficult to survive for very
long but we will we will have to wait
and see i've got two more questions the
first one is just to reflect uh 2019 an
80-seat majority was won this was a
prime minister that had in his power the
opportunity to completely reshape this
country through legislation and the
biggest majority since margaret thatcher
and now he is facing a confidence vote
will he go down as one of the most
unsuccessful conservative prime
ministers in history no i don't think so
actually i think that there's an
enormous amount and my letter to him
says there's an enormous amount which i
and i think every other tory mp should
be grateful to him for and that includes
getting brexit done after the country
voted to leave and it includes winning a
thumping majority as you just said in
2019 it includes getting us out of covid
lockdowns earlier than other people
thought was sensible and it also
includes um leading the international
response on arming ukraine against
russian aggression those are all really
material the problem for me and i think
for others as well is that they don't
either excuse or justify a breach of the
ministerial code and that's you know
that is the the thing that's blotting
out the sun and just finally a lot of
your colleagues are saying don't do this
now don't trigger a civil war don't
trigger a protracted leadership contest
it will annoy voters it will alienate
them
i mean
is this a really bad idea that you are
going to trigger
a leadership crisis in the moment of a
cost of living crisis is it not a bit
irresponsible well i think
your question is is entirely valid but
i'm afraid it's been overtaken by events
because
you know the the 1922 committee
announced this morning that the
threshold has been um has been uh
overcome so there will be a vote this
evening so we'll we'll have to wait and
see but uh i don't think there's ever a
good moment um but now is the moment new
prime minister by the end of the year
i don't know i'll talk to you this
evening once the results of the voter in
but if he survives and can he's
what i'm getting at is even if he wins
the vote can he survive
through to the next election through to
the end of the year i think it will
become increasingly difficult um unless
he can dramatically demonstrate you know
answers and those are very hard for
someone in his position to show okay
john penrose thanks so much for coming
on sky news exclusively actually to talk
to us about your letter really
appreciate that